supply chains are going absolutely nuts
the supply chains are so broke that no
one can agree on how broken they are
they seem to be easing but they still
are broke supply chains are causing all
kinds of mass chaos havoc and
uncertainty around the world they do not
expect traffic to ease as the western
ports continue to be congested until at
least february and maybe even further
this spells disaster for christmas the
holidays and lots and lots of goods that
are trying to get into the united states
during the last couple of years the
united states has been obsessed with
efficiency we have scoured the earth
looking for cheap labor and low cost of
production we have moved our
manufacturing and supply chains offshore
we have sought out the lowest cost
possible but when you pursue efficiency
what you do is you give up all sorts of
resiliency so now we are dependent on
these other manufacturing and supply
chains in other countries and they once
they make their goods or their services
they have to then bring them and import
them into the united states so one of
the big stats that shows just how bad
the congestion and the disruption in the
supply chain has gotten is the cost of
shipping something from china so if we
go ahead and we look at this the cost to
move a container from china to the u.s
west coast fell 26 last week it is down
26 week over week but
it is still 13 295
that is more than three times the high
since the start of the year when the box
cost 4 200
so even though the cost of shipping a
container from china to the us west
coast has dropped 26 week over week it
is still 300 plus percent higher than it
used to be companies that are chartering
their own smaller ships that are
traditionally used for regional trade
and now they're saying let's go little
boy we're going to go across the pacific
ocean these smaller ships can cost twice
as much to operate and the average cost
per box across the pacific is around 30
000
which is nearly 8x or so from what it
cost at the beginning of this year the
price of this stuff the reason why you
should care is that as the cost of
logistical movement goes up whether we
were talking about the containers the
shipping the ports the truck drivers etc
as those costs go up that means that the
end person that is receiving it whether
it's an individual or a business they
increase their prices to accommodate for
their increased expenses when they
increase their prices that means you at
home you pay more this is why you hear a
bunch of people saying oh the supply
chains the supply chains it's the supply
chains that's why prices are going up
why did the supply chains break
it's because we handed a ton of money to
a ton of people for free and they went
on the internet and they went to the
store and they started spending like
drunken sailors there was money falling
out of their pockets and they were just
spending and spending and spending and
asset prices were ripping and house
prices were ripping and stocks were
going up and they were selling it and
they were getting more money and then
they were spending that in the stores
and online and so ultimately what we did
is we ended up constraining or breaking
the supply chains that's a huge huge
problem so who exactly is ordering all
of these ships well they're big
importers as you would expect amazon
walmart home depot and others but just
amazon walmart and home depot account
for one quarter of all imports that come
into the west coast
jeff bezos and his squad of walmart and
home depot literally run the west coast
that pacific movement from china to the
u.s is owned 25 of it by three companies
here in the u.s absolutely nuts and the
current situation in the southern
hemisphere that's not the southern
hemisphere the southern part of
california is that there's around 80 box
ships waiting to unload at los angeles
and long beach for at least two weeks so
there's 80 ships that have waited at
least two weeks to unload they're just
sitting there they're chilling they say
hey we got gear but we can't drop it off
because you guys can't get the boxes out
of the way at the port why can't get the
boxes out of the way at the port because
there's not enough truck drivers to go
and take them so there's lots and lots
of problems there's continued congestion
and so ultimately we got this quote from
lars jensen the ceo of denmark based
versep maritime maritime's just a cool
ass word but lars said quote it could be
months before the logjams ease but if we
don't get more closures at ports the
volumes should become more manageable
after the chinese new year this is
murderers row for the logistics business
they literally have holiday after
holiday after holiday after holiday
after holiday all around the world
everyone wants to know santa claus is
real kids but how do i get the stuff
there maybe he'll drop it off with the
sleigh but also bezos and company they
need to get you goods as well and so it
could be months before those log jams
ease how bad a problem do we think this
is and are we worried yeah it's bad i
mean it's obviously getting a little
better when you look at cost but time
i'm sure will get better also uh the
thing that most people don't realize is
right like i think nike said it a few
months ago that it was taking about 40
days to get things from asia to the west
coast uh shipment wise and now it's
taking over 85 days so if you order
something today it's not getting here
until february right we're in the middle
of november so from a time perspective
it's crazy uh and i think it's going to
put a real constraint on the the amount
and the supply of holiday goods that are
going to be here in the united states
because there's like at any given point
there's 20 50 100 ships sitting outside
of the port in los angeles right now uh
in other and other cities on the west
coast so i think what we're going to see
is there's obviously companies the
larger companies have said we're going
to start shipping this and getting our
own ships here so we don't have to deal
with these uh astronomical rates but
also we're gonna go to other ports we're
gonna go to the east coast we're gonna
go to portland we're gonna go to other
areas that aren't as crowded so so that
we know uh we're not gonna be sitting
out there for 10 days idle in the ship
and our goods are just sitting there
we're going to go to other places where
we can access the port i think what's
going to be interesting is uh how this
plays out over the holidays right and
what we see come from uh not only the
retailers from a price perspective but
consumers where the demand looks if
people turn to digital goods what uh you
know do people buy assets for people for
gifts all that kind of stuff i think is
interesting but it also has to do with
stores over there
manufacturing these goods and i use nike
as an example because they've been
extremely transparent about their
process but what they said was in
vietnam a second wave of covet hit and
they weren't able to have these uh i
think it was when this when the plant
reopened when the manufacturing facility
reopened 80 percent of the workforce
didn't return so literally thousands and
thousands of thousands of employees
didn't return out of fear of covet and
all and everything else going on over
there so not only are goods taking
longer to get here from a shipment
perspective they're also low on
inventory and they're not creating these
goods as fast as possible and nike's
just one example every company that has
major operations over in asia is dealing
with the same stuff right now so i think
that's part of it from a a supply chain
perspective but i think the holidays are
going to be super interesting to watch
john what do you think well i forget who
said it that said if you don't have your
you were talking about if you don't have
your stuff on a cargo ship already on
the way over here this was like a month
and a half ago then it won't be in here
for christmas i think we're going to see
a lot of gift cards and cash and uh
bitcoin like bitcoin and all these other
different type of digital stuff being
given as gifts for christmas it's not
the same feeling but i also worry about
people that a great side hustle that a
lot of people do is drop shipping right
so they'll they'll have a drop shipping
website or something on amazon then when
you buy it there they'll
buy it from somewhere else and then kind
of ship it to you but a lot of that is
in high inventory so you don't want to
pay those high fees for shipping
internationally you can't order in bulk
because it's drop shipping so there's a
bunch of issues that you run into that
um and then yeah the drunken sailor
comment was funny i like to say the
spending money like it's burning a hole
in your pocket but drunken sailor i
think people were generally spending a
lot of money being sitting at home
setting up home offices kind of doing
home workout stuff everything they were
just kind of bored and they were surfing
the internet and buying stuff so supply
chain is going to last a really long
time it's going to last at least
experts are saying until february
i don't expect anything less so i think
another interesting thing is this used
to be an unpopular opinion and something
that no one ever talked about and now
it's become commonplace i think between
amongst a lot of people which is that
the united states and the companies that
operate here uh took manufacturing
stateside uh for granted right and they
didn't look to explore innovation they
didn't look to set up processes and
plants and do all this manufacturing
here in the united states except for
abroad because it was easy it was
cheaper
and it was just uh from an economic
standpoint it was the right thing to do
and i think what this has created is the
need to go and further develop that part
of the supply chain right you need goods
that are here in the united states in
case things like this happen where
you're not able to transport them they
cost more money people are not coming
into work there's a variety of different
reasons but i think what it's going to
ultimately do is it's going to start up
that innovation process here in the
united states again of people looking to
manufacture goods and services here and
produce them at a much quicker uh maybe
i'll be at a little bit more expensive
rate but eventually that'll come down as
innovation starts to occur